and then they handed me give me only me
win game hey what is going on YouTube I
know the background scenery is not as
cute as it used to be well [ __ ] it just
came back from Japan I'm tired of [ __ ]
still do the video well YouTube you
asked questions and I'm here to answer
them and whether my answers are credible
or not no idea but recently subscriber
Jackie Lau ass how do I get the girl to
like me should I be myself Spock some
sort of in play or should I try to be
different from who I normally air this
is actually a very good an interesting
question but before we get started on
this number one I already know what half
y'all already thinking why would you ask
Amy I mean I bet you can't even get any
[ __ ] first of all dude you don't
[ __ ] know me and second of all second
of all [ __ ] my personality on point I
got a personnel ago would love to be
around I know what you talking about
what she touched me dirty not too sure
about that
I sure as hell make her giggle the [ __ ]
out of myself Oh David you crazy
best giggle all the way to my damn cheek
but in all honesty I'm actually one of
the best people you want to ask on how
to get a girl and you want to know why
because I am an average [ __ ]
that's on the fatty side and somehow I
still got women to talk to me and that's
no lie listen you don't want to ask
somebody who's good-looking with abs of
steel on how to get women because even
they don't know they don't have to do
[ __ ] good-looking people just do this
was the longer you try to [ __ ] and then
the girl be like we ain't got it like
this son we basic we got to show them
that the face is average the body is
whack with a personality on point and
the dick is good or in my case C+ at
best you know what I'm not I'm not an
attitude you want to get naked Bo we the
type of dudes that have the somehow
trick a woman into touching us sexually
do you like any idea what I had to do
when I was a single man huh how to set
an emotional trap on a girl like I was
Elmer Fudd and that [ __ ] with a wily
rabbit I'm hunting for some [ __ ] now
I'm not saying you [ __ ] ugly you
obviously better-looking to me but you
ain't that [ __ ] tight you know what's
gonna happen when you try to do a good
looking first [ __ ] you transfer
crows are you serious he just said the
same thing you should be yourself to the
max because you yourself should always
be more than enough and why do I say
this you ask
that's some [ __ ] where i'ma tell you
you're an awesome person I personally
don't know you you could be a baby
touching your [ __ ] sick freak because
if you choose to be somebody else from
the get-go and you grab that person you
do realize that you have to be that
person you pretended to be for the rest
of the relationship that's like dressing
up for Halloween but never taking off
your costume how mad would you be if you
dressed up as the Blue Ranger met this
girl on Halloween and that's the only
[ __ ] you could be for the rest
of your life all she ever wanted was
that power any big okay see that's the
[ __ ] problem
I'm not Blue Ranger it was for Halloween
once I want to take this off name's
David David [ __ ] it's David see oh my
god get off me I love you for for you
are my daughter Ranger David Luke Harry
David bloop are you sure why are you
transgene bish being yourself is the
best because you don't really have to
try you just are anything you just have
to be confident the fact that you have
quality that someone of the opposite sex
finds attractive and I know this advice
is completely cliche as [ __ ] but just be
yourself and I only say this only if you
know you're weird in the sense of you
have like you know quirks but if you
like to socially Annette the rude dirty
dumbass [ __ ] that no no don't be
yourself find somebody else to be and
just stick to that what what's up
YouTube I am back from Japan I hope you
guys liked that video if you have other
questions and topics that you want to be
involved in these vlogs go ahead and
leave a question or comment below in the
comment box or you guys can go to my
facebook pen 10 page pancakes you guys
can go to my facebook fan page
facebook.com slash D so comedy hit me up
on Twitter hit me up on that
instagrams my friends and Acacia know
that I do snapchat see y'all next week
what's up
Rick I smell it oh my love you are
strong
get off me
seriously watch this baby look at this
but it is just speaking no no let's say
this baby watch this for this I've got
this just for you discount it for this
enough
what what what